all right everybody let's talk about
this first story Elon Musk claims risk
of his assassination is quite
significant and uh a little bit more
than that he said quote if I committed
suicide it's not real as soon as I heard
him say that I had to tweet it out when
he was releasing the Twitter files he
said it was gonna be at 5 PM then all of
a sudden he's like okay it's gonna be in
an hour then he goes dark and everyone's
like what's happening the joke across
Twitter was last minute phone call from
Hillary Clinton
so he says frankly the risk of something
bad happened to me or even literally
being shot is quite significant it's not
that hard to kill somebody if you wanted
to so hopefully they don't and fate fate
Smiles upon the situation with me and it
does not happen there's definitely some
risk there
I I gotta say the first thing is uh does
that seem like the typical reaction from
someone who genuinely feels like they'll
lose their life and I'm not saying he's
wrong or that's not true I'm saying I
guess you'd expect him to react
differently right Abe Lincoln had a
similar thing where he was just like
they wanted him to have all the
Securities like you know what if they
kill me they kill me and he had a dream
a few nights before he was killed of him
walking through the White House people
were crying in his dream he was like
what happened and they were like the
president's been killed and then he woke
up Lincoln and he was like what that was
weird a couple days later he was shot
and killed so once I think if you're at
peace with yourself you just have to be
your best self and damn be the
consequences but
you know I mean what like he said if
everyone in the world wants to kill you
how long can you survive I mean seven
minutes I don't think it's everyone I
think it's a certain select few of
individuals some of them uh you know
rhyming with uh Hillary you know sorry
he just literally said Hillary pardon
part of my friendship but I think
there's another area yeah chillery you
know but I think there's a reason uh
Epstein was trending Friday night when
we had the delay of the Twitter files I
think we're living in a society where
intelligence agencies do have things
like heart attack guns and if you look
at these latest Twitter files who did
they go after the intelligence agencies
that we know were Conjuring up lies in
order to try to push a narrative and a
story and to suppress a story that would
make a political party look uh good when
of course the reality of it was that
they were bad that there was a lot of
horrible things you want to say
something I just want to pull I want to
confirm the source of uh this is from
all all that's interesting.com the heart
attack gunfighter Dart made from Frozen
shellfish toxin that would enter the
target's bloodstream and kill them in
mere minutes without leaving a trace
it's like in the 60s or 70s
1975. that was yeah through the I think
the commission hearings uh the Warren
Commission hearings I believe if I stand
corrected that there was uh a lot of
disclosure with what the intelligence
agencies were doing uh behind the scenes
and this is this is decades and decades
ago you can only imagine what they have
now so with Elon Musk saying that he's
taking his security uh you know more
significantly uh taking taking his
security more seriously than before I
mean obviously he's pissing off a lot of
powerful people that do
Epstein people let's just be real here
let's just be honest here with ourselves
you know one thing that I often thought
about with stuff like this in Trump I
heard that one thing I've heard we've
talked about the reason Trump likes fast
food so much is that when you walk into
a McDonald's the Burger's already made
so when you order it they can't tamper
with it and there's like a fear I don't
know if that's true but that's a gross
excuse to eat McDonald's I just I it's
but it makes sense but yeah logical I
mean I worry about this stuff like you
never know we live in country so for the
most part people come out fist bump me
and they're really excited you know like
I don't but I I'm if I go into like a
deep blue area where people are you know
crazy leftists or whatever I gotta worry
about my food getting messed with or
something
food is the Avenue through which they
typically do something like this which
is why we run a tight ship in my
kitchens but uh you know it's funny when
I hear that about the shellfish and my
this is how sick my mind is I
immediately go to like braised shellfish
with garlic and white wine and herbs and
all of that uh uh you know with the Elon
piece of this I I think two things
number one kind of Heisenberg's
principle which I think I'm using this
properly right the active observation
ultimately affects that of which is
being observed so if he goes out there
and throws this out into the public you
know that act right and then under the
observation he could change the
trajectory so get it out there talk
about it let it be public and then
ultimately that that could
hypothetically change uh whether you
know however you want to look at this
change what's going to happen number two
he's a businessman at heart right and
the more he talks the more he puts out
these kind of hyperbolic statements the
more people are going to go on Twitter
more people they're going to Tweet about
it I mean he's driving business by
virtue of his own narrative and it's
kind of brilliant because we see the
numbers we see the activity is up and
and that that ticks everybody off
because they talk about how oh well
Twitter's gonna shut down this weekend
yeah and now the headlines came out
after he he published and produced how
successful Twitter was over the past
three to four weeks well that's just a
smoke screen those are going to go down
and just the correction it was the
church hearings that really uh released
the information of the heart attack gun
and a lot of other horrible things that
the intelligence agencies were doing in
secret uh but we also have to understand
that this was uh Elon responding
directly to questions being asked to him
specifically if he's going to be
suicidal at any point in time in his
life and and this spurred on this
reaction which of course everyone's
talking about as we're still waiting for
the Twitter files 2.0 to be released
that we're hearing or in the hands of uh
Barry Weiss so there's still a lot more
there's some people saying that this was
a nothing Burger there's a lot of people
saying that this is the a huge a huge
reveal that I think is going to have
significant changes in our society but
it all depends I I guess where you stand
politically it's a Smoking Gun I mean
the Twitter files so one of the things
they're mentioning is that that the the
request from the DNC the specific links
were nudes of Hunter Biden Now Fair
Point uh I can understand why somebody
would be like yeah I don't want those up
but why is the DNC making those requests
and not you know say hunter Biden for
personal reasons so the first they have
to consider the Democratic National
Committee was trying to get these
private images from a private citizen
who was not running for office removed
so when the left comes out and says
Hunter Biden's not the president not
running he's not relevant okay well then
why is the DNC trying to well because
obviously it's relevant the second thing
is the images corroborate the laptop is
real
if someone came out and said look at
this email that's fake how do I know
that email's real because here's a
picture of Hunter Biden in a private you
know revealing circumstance that he took
himself that was along with it okay not
a guarantee the email's real but it does
lend some evidence to the fact so when
they start when the Democrats literally
are taking down images of of a third
party who's not running for office
that's bad but more importantly when it
came to the laptop in general the the
files reveal that they had no policy
justification for removing it argued
about how they had no policy
justification for removing the laptop
story did it anyway and then a big
mistake metai be made with all due
respect because I think that Matt does a
great job and I think he's fantastic
Jack busovic posted the FEC the federal
election documents from yoel Roth of
Twitter saying the FBI contacted us said
there would be hacked materials related
to Hunter Biden then they just
arbitrarily removed that story BS the
FBI like Mark Zuckerberg said reached
out to them and said the story's coming
get rid of it what did uh taibi what
mistake did Tybee make did he not
include that taibis he didn't and he
said that I've seen no evidence of
government involvement in the censorship
of this and then later jackposovic
posted an FEC document from fec.gov
where Joel Roth was like yes they
contacted me yes they said the
information that Hunter Biden was coming
and that and to be careful about it Mark
Zuckerberg said exact same thing yeah
and the New York Post released the story
today talking about the FBI's hack and
leak operation which they had weekly
meetings with a big Tech social media
companies and they came to them and they
said hey Hunter Biden is a target of a
hack and leak operation that's going
after him before the story even was
public so they knew they probably knew
that the New York Post was working on
this story they knew it was going to go
public so they preemptively spread this
information spread lies in order to
confuse and stop a narrative that would
make the uncoming political party look
uh bad that that right there is is is
very very Sinister nasty actions that
are absolutely playing totally unfair
when it comes to this political
landscape and I have to stress it's not
just the FBI according to this document
from fec.gov since he wrote since 2018
I've had regular meetings the office of
the Director of National Intelligence
the Department of Homeland Security the
FBI and Industry peers regarding
election security he goes on to mention
that these expectations of hack and leak
operations were discussed throughout
2022 I also learned these meetings that
there were rumors that a hack and leak
operation would involve Hunter Biden so
to clarify DHS FBI industry peers the
dni were in contact with Twitter
consistently for years and in 2020 said
negative information about Hunter Biden
is coming who's this FEC who's the I I
noticed Noel Roth okay as you can see
right here signed Joel Roth head of site
Integrity Twitter Inc December 17 2020.
I I think that the writings on the wall
with government collusion with big Tech
I mean I think it's obvious and it's
becoming more apparent and more legally
Justified if we're going to make these
claims with evidence like this but what
what when I'm reading the patterns of
humanity what it looks like right now is
this is a chance to step up each of us
because it's like whack you know the
whack-a-mole game someone steps up and
tries to change society they get whacked
and that's been happening since Kennedy
since I don't know I'm claiming that I
don't have I mean I've got a lot of
evidence that Kennedy was obviously
Kennedy was killed but I'm not saying
who did I don't know who did it I know
apparently anyway
the chance this is where we all have to
step up and take some of the the focus
onto ourselves because if we let Elon we
think he's some superhero he's just a
vulnerable guy so I want to be on you
know team Humanity here
yeah look I think that where this is
going to start to focus is on the um
private versus public element here
private versus government element
because what you hear is the argument is
no well this is a private Enterprise
they were you know it was a private
citizen at the time Joe Biden he was
just a candidate he wasn't involved with
government and look this is you know a
private company and that's the argument
that's being made but what's really
interesting is it was the DNC which once
again you can claim that is private but
then you have public government
officials as part of the DNC right so
you have what could hypothetically be
considered in more of the business or
the corporate world piercing the
corporate veil right and by that I mean
is is that yes so you have all of this
through this shell company the DNC
that's private but then you have public
influencers or stakeholders that are on
that private committee or that private
you know group that are then influencing
this through so then did you pierce that
veil in the in the food world right as a
franchisor I am responsible by way of
new laws for the labor practices of a
franchisee that was a recent ruling
right and that gets into that kind of
that corporate public-private piece of
this and so if in the private business
world I'm responsible as a franchisor
for what my franchisee does even though
I have nothing to do with it by way of
just that connection well then
government should be held to the exact
same standard
there was a very interesting article by
Jonathan Turley that was released also
that was titled six degrees from James
Baker a familiar figure re-emerges with
the release of the Twitter files that
details how you know a lot of this was
was centered around from the very
beginning this whole Russian collusion
narrative this whole larger agenda here
from Central figures within the federal
government that were engineering a lot
of this and when we kind of look at this
we gotta we kind of got to ask ourselves
obviously there was some incentive by
big Tech social media companies to try
to make the Democrats win since the
Democrats are more favorable towards uh
big Tech monopolies rather than of
course Republicans that were kind of
threatening to put them in check
threatening in in not even a real way
but but kind of soft-handed way kind of
hinting that they that they might be
interested in doing something like the
Republicans always do and then they kind
of back off and scare just like
teenagers trying to go up to a girl uh
that's that's essentially what a lot of
the Republicans did here and I think
this is you know one reason why to
speculate uh what's really going on here
is it the Private Industry or is it the
the public industry who's really
responsible here to me it doesn't matter
they're all in bed together a lot of
these individuals are working together a
lot of these individuals know that they
need to depend on each other they have
blackmail on each other and to me this
is a no-brainer that they're codifying
the elections for their own personal
benefit
and but to go along with the private
argument right let's Galvanize that
argument and say okay it's all private
then and anybody can do what they want
and that's the argument it's done well
then why why are people going after Elon
so much it's a private company he can do
whatever he wants so you can't kind of
scream this guy is falling on one side
but then use the same argument against
or for whichever side you're on
um and I think that that's something
that's just being ignored in all of this
when when when the two sides are
battling it out it was interesting to
see the White House response to all of
this they finally decided to release an
official statement saying that the
Twitter files were quote a distraction
in old news that are diverting attention
from Twitter's quote hate and
disinformation so very weaponized very
kind of Orwell unit terms used by the
White House in response to all of this
and Elon Musk looks like he's not
backing down there's going to be more
releases in the future there's also a
lot of rumors that he's going to be
starting a medical experts panel that's
going to be questioning the government's
logic when it comes to health advice and
he also came out recently and talked
about how he thinks that the FTA x
scandal is a lot bigger than what people
make it out to be and he's claiming that
it's it's it could be nearly one billion
dollars that was given to Democrats via
dark Channels with untraceable money so
there's a lot of things happening behind
the scenes that we don't know about but
it it definitely is a very fascinating
battle with Elon Musk saying he's afraid
for his life essentially trying to say
that he's not going to be Epstein who's
saying that the the risk for
assassination is real thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time